there's a story that we're you know
could you prepare prepare and prepare
but there are some things you cannot
prepare for was it when he was when you
went on one night I went there was one
night did that show for eight months and
we chose eight shows a week eight months
and and my character that we didn't show
biz mother from hell and she I start at
the back of the auditorium and the kids
are on stage and they're starting the
show and I've you know I'm immortal sing
out Louise come and dress coat hat and
also she has a little dog a real dog and
I'm standing at the back and I my coat
was a bit uncomfortable about all her
number so I sing it and as soon as I
started speaking I'm walking down the
aisle I thought there's something in my
there's something in our that's the
mouse
there'll be a there's a mouse walking up
my arm the inside of my coat I'm fine
no no a mouse that obviously as my coat
was lying in the dressing room it
crawled into my are my coat all lovely
lovely snuggly lovely suddenly shouted
woman put the coat on shouting the mouse
[Laughter]
I'm so they'll sit out always come on I
got talkee talkee talkee all the way up
off the stage mousie up here
talkie-talkie singing you know see
and then I thought you know the jump do
that Mouse will fly Mouse didn't do that
obviously then at the end of the scene
do you and someone I saw that now she
came down at the back I just ran off I
can't stop just keep going see there's a
lesson there cute
[Music]